[Musique]
on est ici dans le local technique les
bâtiments de l'école centrale
le bâtiment a qui est situé sur la zac
du moulin un des premiers bâtiments qui
est alimenté en chaleur et en froid
sur la zac ainsi que le bâtiment b qui
aujourd'hui alimenté aussi depuis tels
que quelques jours on a derrière moi une
installation type de livraison de
chaleur et de froid par des échangeur à
plaques qui permettent d'alimenter
l'ensemble du bâtiment avec de l'eau
chaude et de l'eau aux combis glace et
l'eau chaude
areva se sentent degrés l'eau glacée est
ainsi degré et permet de répondre à tous
les besoins en chaleur et en froid du
bâtiment cette installation est assez
caractéristique aura retrouvé la même
dans tous les bâtiments qui sont
raccordés
elle est plus ou moins grosses en
fonction des besoins de du bâtiment ces
installations pour fonctionner elles ont
besoin d'être raccordés au réseau
raccordés au réseau qu'est ce que c'est
c'est à dire qu'il ya des canalisations
qui traverse le bâtiment et puis qui
circulent en voirie pour les rejoindre
les installations de production donc là
en terme de réseau de canalisations
environ 60% des canalisations sont posés
en varient mais les travaux sont pas
réduits à ça il ya aussi des travaux de
préparation qui seront lancés pour
pouvoir réaliser les forages sur chacune
des 2 ac
les forages c'est
4 puis au total deux baraques et ses
travaux commencent mois de février et
vont se terminer à la fin de la neige
travaux assez long pour aller chercher
la ressource de la nappe de l'albien
quitte à 700 mètres de profondeur au fur
et à mesure de la livraison des
bâtiments il faut les alimenter en
chaleur et en froid en fonction des
besoins aussi en eau chaude sanitaire et
donc pour la fin du mois de mars de
nouveaux bâtiments qui sont prévues sur
le programme serendipity
et puis à fin mai début juin juste avant
l'été à d'autres bâtiments de paris
habitat qui sera des logements tout
comme ceux de cm 10 city qui eux seront
donc alimenter ans chez l'un en froid et
le programme de raccordement ne s'arrête
jamais puisque d'ici la fin 2010 est un
autre bâtiment et puis en 2018
une série d'une quinzaine de bâtiments
qui sont prévues est alimenté en chaleur
en froid et en eau chaude sanitaire
poule a en besoin